à valéry giscard d'estaing au conseil
des ministres d'ouverture c'est une
politique de responsabilité de liberté
vingt nouveaux secrétaires d'état le
gouvernement définitivement constitué ce
soit airbus eastern airlines achètent
aujourd'hui 23 appareils marée noire les
bretons indemnisés mais inquiet pour
l'avenir
monsieur bonsoir rideau rideau sur une
pièce en quatre actes la pièce post
électorale du gouvernement premier acte
raymond barre réuni son ancien
gouvernement mercredi dernier et dit au
revoir
12e à deux jours plus tard raymond barre
reconduit dit bonjour
troisième acte hier il nomme ses
ministres et puis quatrième acte donc
aujourd'hui un acte en deux tableaux la
réunion du conseil des ministres avec
tous les nouveaux
et puis il y à une heure la désignation
d'essen khattab état qui leur seront
rattachés désignation annoncée comme
hier par jean françois poncet secrétaire
d'état auprès du premier ministre
jacques dominati relations avec le
parlement
jacques limouzy recherche pierre aigrain
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
la justice
monique pelletier secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de la santé et de la
famille daniel hoeffel secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
paul dijoux collectivités locales
marc bécam secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre des affaires étrangères olivier
stirn secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre du travail et de la
participation formation professionnelle
jacques le genre travailleurs manuels et
immigrés lionel stoléru emplois féminins
nicole pasquier secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre de l'environnement et du
cadre de vie logement
marcel cavaillé environnement françois
delmas secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'éducation
jacques pelletier secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'agriculture
jacques fouchier secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'industrie
petite et moyenne industrie jean pierre
proulx tôt je remercie d'ailleurs nous
ne venons pas sur les visages qui vous
sont déjà familiers de ceux qui restent
ou qu'ils permutent voici en revanche
les petits nouveaux de la classe les
sacs est à d'état qui entre dans le 3ème
cabinet va nous laisser là on commence
par jacqueline oui oui jacques limouzy a
été nommé secrétaire d'état auprès du
premier ministre il est chargé des
relations avec le parlement il a 51 ans
il est né à castres dans le tarn et il a
été élu deux députés en 1967 après avoir
été chargé de mission auprès du ministre
de l'intérieur
plusieurs fois secrétaire d'état
monsieur limouzy a déjà été chargé des
relations avec le parlement dans le
cabinet chaban delmas de 69 à 72 pierre
aigrain maintenant moins connu encore il
est secrétaire d'état à la recherche
depuis ce soir 53 ans physicien de
profession il n'a aucun mandat
parlementaire monsieur aigrain a été
successivement directeur scientifique au
ministère des armées puis professeur de
technologie à cambridge aux états unis
avant de devenir spécialiste dans le
domaine des circuits électroniques des
semi conducteurs gagnait lefel daniel
offe elle est secrétaire d'état à la
santé à la famille 47 ans monsieur fait
les docteurs en droit il a déjà fait
partie de plusieurs cabinets notamment
du ministre de la défense nationale en
54 il est actuellement membre de la
commission du développement économique
d'alsace et depuis septembre dernier
daniel au fait les sénateurs du bar à
françois delmas assainir le mobilier
secrétaire d'état à l'environnement 64
ans avocat de formation monsieur delmas
s'est fait battre à montpellier aux
dernières municipales avant d'être réélu
brillamment député de l'hérault le 19
mars dernier
monsieur delmas et membre du bureau
politique du parti république jacques
pelletier un sénateur jacques pelletier
secrétaire d'état à l'éducation 48 ans
monsieur pelletier est sénateur depuis
1966 est inscrit au groupe de la gauche
démocratique au sénat monsieur pelletier
est agriculteur et a été secrétaire des
réformateurs à vendre
devenir vice président de l'aco d'aires
de pique à jacques rouch est maintenant
secrétaire d'état l'agriculture 64 ans
monsieur fouchy et vétérinaire dans les
deux sèvres maire de saint maixent il a
été élu député de la propre la première
fois en 1958 inscrit à l'assemblée
nationale au groupe de l'union centriste
il était président depuis 1973 de la
commission de la production et des
échanges par jean pierre protot il est
jean piat prouteau a été nommé ce soir
secrétaire d'état chargé de la petite et
moyenne industrie 45 ans messieurs proto
est actuellement directeur de la
mutualité agricole et conseiller de
michèle de bâtisses le président de la
leaf est né sera auparavant il était
grand maître du grand orient de france
pas donc pour les nouveaux leurs grands
frères ont déjà commencé à travailler ce
matin puisque le chef de l'état les
avait réunis en conseil conseil un peu
solennel vous me posiez puisque précédé
d'une arrivée en fanfare
un conseil qui n'avait pas d'ordre du
jour particulier et qui a été presque
entièrement consacré à une importante
déclaration du président de la
république
le président a d'abord rappelé que les
ministres se trouvaient devant une
période de trois ans sans élection à
vocation nationale et qu ainsi il
pourrait s'attaquer en profondeur aux
vrais problèmes du pays
cinq élections nationales en six ans a
dit valéry giscard d'estaing c'était
trop une partie l'énergie nationale
c'est gaspiller dans la tente des
échéances et puis chef de l'état a
défini les directions l'action du
gouvernement pour les années à venir
l'orientation est essentielle c'est
maintenir le rang et la position de la
france dans bon
en france même les orientations sont
maintenir les développer le redressement
économique en parvenant si possible un
taux de croissance supérieur à celui des
roses à c'est le progrès social
c'est-à-dire la revalorisation des bas
salaires notamment des ouvriers des
travailleurs manuels ainsi que
l'amélioration de la situation des
familles et enfin le troisième objectif
ce sont les libertés et c'est à dire le
meilleur exercice des responsabilités au
niveau local notamment de la commune et
la lutte contre les excès de
l'administration sur le président de la
république appelle la marée blanche de
la paperasse oui il faut ajouter à ce
qu'elle dit pierre hunt for parole de
l'elysée que valéry giscard d'estaing a
défini sa conception de l'ouverture qui
se marquera par une recherche du
dialogue avec l'opposition et par des
mesures concrètes telles qu'un accès
plus large à l'information ou bien le
financement régulier des partis
politiques alors un petit commentaire
rapide noël sur cette nouvelle
composition du gouvernement depuis que
sont connus les socata d'état une
proposition qui a commenté d'ailleurs le
premier miss me barre tout à l'heure
nous est dit sur le perron de l'elysée
nous indiquer les trois grands axes de
ces nouvelles dominations premier axe un
souci d'efficacité deuxième axe une
volonté de meilleure représentation
régionale et troisièmement l'ouverture
politique alors une efficacité alors
l'efficacité soul et pour simplifier
elle se résume par exemple dans le
maintien et la présence de trois
secrétaires d'état au ministère du
travail devenu le ministère du travail
et de la participation
madame basque et messieurs ce tollé rue
legendre elle est symbolisée aussi par
notre gouvernement d'un homme comme
monsieur pierre et grains qui est un
scientifique de grand renom et qui était
la recherche scientifique et cette
nomination est un peu à rapprocher de
celle d'hier de monsieur andré giraud à
l'industrie alors la volonté de
reprendre national sa veux dire que
certaines régions sont mieux pris en
partant mais c'est le cas de l'ensemble
sud sud ouest qui sera représentée par
exemple par messieurs cavaillé limouzy
et telle masse et dijon à l'ouverture
politique et l'ouverture politique elle
symbolise l essentiellement dans deux
hommes
monsieur jean pierre protot que jean
louis lahaye sen a présenté tout à l'air
qui appartient à la famille
radical et quelqu'un dirait ce concept
de la franc maçonnerie est le deuxième
homme si je puis dire c'est monsieur
jacques pelletier sénateurs centristes
centriste d'opposition qui est très
proche de monsieur caillé alors cette
fois on peut dire qu'il ya un
renouvellement des hommes s'étaient pas
le cas hier en revanche sur deux qui est
à nouveau ce soir 8 sur celle du travail
allemand maintenant une série
d'informations politiques une
déclaration de politique générale du
premier ministre à l'assemblée les 19 et
20 avril changement dans le cabinet de
raymond barre le nouveau directeur de
cabinet et philippe mestres préfet b
région des pays de loire qui remplace
daniel distincts qui reste attaché
auprès du premier ministre or de toute
hiérarchie
conséquence du remaniement jean pierre
soisson qui rentre au gouvernement
quitte le secrétariat général du parti
républicain et propose comme successeur
l'ancien secrétaire d'état jacques blanc
jacques blanc qui a été reçue tout à
l'heure par le président de la
république autres visiteurs de la
journée à l'elysée roger chinaud puis au
delà des les deux hommes auront pu
évoquer avec le chef de l'état l'échec
de leurs négociations avec l'opposition
il avait proposé une présidence de
commission socialiste le ps a décliné
l'offre estimant que les idées
d'ouverture avancée par l'elysée n'ont
pas été retenus par la majorité
parlementaire
en conséquence aussi donc maintenant le
nouveau visage des présidences de
commission à l'assemblée commission des
finances la plus prestigieuse la plus
demandée président robert andré vivien
rp rapporteur général fernand y car il
est président de la commission des lois
monsieur jean foyer rpr ancien garde des
sceaux il l'était déjà dans la
précédente législature affaires
étrangères président maurice couve de
murville rpr et ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères là encore pas de
changement défense nationale et forces
armées président et spécialistes le
général marcel bigeard udf nouvelle élue
production échanges président michel
durafour udf ancien ministre de
l'économie et du travail
affaires culturelles et sociales
président monsieur bergé rpr ancien
titulaire du poste auteurs le rapport
sur la sécurité sociale premier dossier
couvriront les députés celui de
l'élargissement du quota français au
fonds monétaire international fmi
dossier épineux pour le rpr même s'il ne
se présente pas sous la même forme qu'il
ya six mois
certains considèrent qu'il s'agira là
d'une épreuve de vérité pour le rpr très
réticent à l'égard de ce projet le rpr
qui s'est réuni hier soir en comité
central et qui a décidé de proposer une
réforme des statuts au congrès
extraordinaire que jacques chirac a
convoqué pour dimanche à paris si ce
projet est adopté jacques chaban delmas
ce sera la part tenir aux instances
dirigeantes du prpm tout comme les
personnalités qui je cite assume des
fonctions d'arbitrage international ou
gouvernementales chaque jour à delmas
s'était jusqu'à présent membre de droit
de ses instances en sa qualité d'ancien
premier ministre c'est donc apparemment
la réponse du berger à la bergère
après la victoire du maire de bordeaux
sur edgar faure gars forts qui était le
candidat jacques chirac bouillonnement
aussi chez les radicaux de gauche ou
michel crépeau député maire de la
rochelle et candidat à la présidence de
son parti
robert fabre et je vous le rappelle
démissionnaire enfin au pc pas de crise
pour georges marchais une contestation
de quelques camarades seulement sur 630
mille un point c'est tout a dit georges
marchais ce matin sur france inter sur
le marché qui a par ailleurs répété que
l'échec de la gauche incombait
uniquement au parti socialiste c'est
tout pour la politique
valéry giscard d'estaing va l'espace de
48 heures s'extraire de ces réalités
intérieur pour participer au sommet
européen de copenhague qui réunira neuf
chefs d'état ou de gouvernement demain
et après demain le plan république
entente il proposait une mini sciatique
européenne pour essayer de régler les
problèmes monétaires internationaux nous
en parlerons demain avec nos envoyés
spéciaux
il existe aussi une europe du chômage
voulaient d'hier en annonçant un sujet
qui n'est jamais arrivé c'est la journée
organisée par la confédération des
syndicats européens qui regroupe 40
millions de travailleurs est destiné à
sensibiliser l'opinion sur les problèmes
de l'emploi et bien les manifestations
se sont encore poursuivi aujourd'hui à
travers l'europe
yahoo
l'europe des 9 contre 6 millions de
chômeurs les candidats à l'emploi sont
toujours plus nombreux regardez ce
tableau en bas c'est l'évolution de la
population qui est un emploi depuis 1960
en hausse et la population qui arrivent
sur le marché du travail
elle s'accroît jusqu'en 1985 et diminue
ensuite pour empêcher l'écart entre les
deux courbes de s'agrandir il faut une
croissance d'au moins 4 5%
ces nouveaux candidats à l'emploi ce
sont les jeunes les femmes dont la venue
au travail représente un phénomène
social profond et puis moins de
personnes montent actuellement l'âge des
parties rentrée c'est une satisfaction
que de constater que depuis deux ans la
conscience va croissant dans tous les
pays membres que nous sommes tous
engagés sur le même bateau et qu'en
définitive la pire des solutions serait
d'exporter le chômage
nous savons tous qu'il y a comme
tentation protectionniste mais nous
pensons que dans tous les milieux de la
communauté l'on prend conscience du fait
que s'enfermer derrière les prêts les
frontières c'est aggraver encore la
situation
je pense personnellement que la marche
et commet la communauté européenne sont
peut-être une des une des principales
raisons une des principales défense dont
nous disposons contre un accroissement
en boule de neige de la crise actuelle
tout en cherchant à mettre au point une
politique plus active de l'emploi la
commission européenne lance l'idée d'une
répartition du travail
ça consiste à considérer qu'il existe un
certain volume d'emploi et qu'on peut
essayer de le partager entre un nombre
plus grand de travailleurs en réduisant
la durée du travail des diverses façons
c'est une formule très délicate impliqué
dans les résultats sur l'emploi ne sont
pas automatiques elle suppose aussi une
grande concertation au niveau européen
est un accord des partenaires sociaux
les syndicats pour leur part sont
convaincus la nécessité d'une action et
d'une solution européenne
nous croyons nous sommes arrivés à un
seuil critique du brain du journal qui
impose absolument que nous résistions à
cette poussée dont posés les uns et les
autres à cette poussée je dirais de
nationalisme économique d'exportation à
tout prix et qu'ensemble nous ayons une
action positive et convergents
nous croyons nous que il faut
effectivement répartir autrement travail
mais sans diminution de salaire
c'est la position de la confédération
européenne des syndicats en allant vers
les 35 heures de la durée hebdomadaire
du travail la cinquième semaine de
congés payés l'abaissement du droit à la
retraite est aussi l'amélioration de la
scolarité et de la formation
professionnelle des gens il y a tout un
vaste champ à discuter si la communauté
est prête à en discuter au plan européen
la confédération européenne des
syndicats est tout à fait prête à
négocier sur ces bases deuxième promesse
que nous avions faite hier un reportage
sur le suicide de ce commerçant de
chaumont qui avait fait l'objet d'un
redressement fiscal
ses obsèques se sont déroulées
aujourd'hui il en signe de deuil
la plupart des magasins de la ville ont
baissé leurs stores bernard marchetti
une équipe d'antenne 2 on essayait de
comprendre sur place pourquoi ce
commerçant s'était suicidé c'est
l'immeuble à chaumont de la direction
des impôts austère et noir il illustre
assez bien l'idée que certains
contribuables se font du fisc celle
d'une administration - soucieuse de
service public que de répression avec
des mots qui font peur avertissement et
redressement commun justice commandement
comme à l'armé employée par des
contrôleurs et des inspecteurs comme
dans la police
la crainte qu'elles inspirent encore et
peut être pour beaucoup dans le suicide
de gilles ce créneau 42 ans propriétaire
de ce magasin à qui venait d'être
notifié un redressement fiscal
les fonctionnaires sont montois eux
aussi désolé par ce drame ont pourtant
la conscience tranquille
la vérification de comptabilité été
conduites dans le respect le plus strict
des règles de procédure j'en ai suivi
personnellement le déroulement
j'ai rencontré madame feu nous je puis
vous assurer que l'agent qui en a été
chargé la conduite de la manière la plus
sérieuse et la plus objective
c'est un très jeune âge emparé t6 de 20
jeunes agents effectivement mais qui
avait la qualification nécessaire qui
était encadrée en permanence par
l'inspecteur confirmés et suivi tout au
long du déroulement des procédures par
un inspecteur principal personnellement
dans quoi cet agent vous ne feriez aucun
mot pour harcèlement
mais dans une petite ville il faut tenir
compte aussi de l'opinion des voisins et
aux yeux de gilles feno le redressement
fiscal fondé portant sur de simples
erreurs et non pas sur une prod
quelconque a pu apparaître comme une
sanction infamante rien
les morts pour rien tout simplement
parce qu'il n'a pas supportée petit et
tracasseries mais que voulez-vous il
dormait plus je ne pouvais pas tenir
alors il n'a pas supporté ça et c'est
pourquoi le mot qu'il a laissé eric dis
moi qui tu l'as dis pas par contre c'est
de devoir me justifier que tout comme le
dernier des oiseaux volent se
débrouillait si vous voulez à nous deux
pour arriver à quelque chose pour avoir
comme tous les français veulent leur
maison pis leur beau jardin c'était tout
ce qu'on demande et puis voilà voilà
alors voyez on aurait fait comme
beaucoup mais tout bouffer du tricot fur
et à mesure et voilà on n'en serait pas
là aujourd'hui purement énorme et des
souvenirs nicollin n'a pu des regrets
airbus continue à marquer des points
après une série d'options voici les
commande ferme celle de la compagnie
eastern airlines qui vient il ya deux
heures de signer un contrat avec airbus
industrie 23 appareils la compagnie
aérienne avait déjà testé quatre depuis
quelques mois sur la ligne new york
miami et en croire jacques simon louis
saporito l'airbus s'était taillé un joli
succès sur la ligne de ta des quatre
airbus utilisé par la compagnie
américaine depuis le mois de décembre
il fait deux fois par jour la navette
entre new york les médias portent ici et
la floride
le taux de remplissage est assez élevé
et sa consommation en carburant est un
quart inférieur à celle de ses
concurrents
les dirigeants dit stern ont donc des
bénéfices et c'est très important aux
états unis ils en ont tiré des
conclusions immédiat c'est pourquoi le
contrat de 23 airbus a été signé par la
compagnie eastern airlines
trente millions de personnes non chaque
année dans un avion de l'histone
airlines la deuxième compagnie
américaine d'aviation avec un réseau qui
dessert toutes les grandes villes de la
côte est de la floride à la frontière du
canada frank baumann l'ancien astronaute
qui fut le premier homme a tourné autour
de la lune en 1968 est aujourd'hui à
saint quentin le président dise turner
là c'est lui le premier qui a compris
que les européens et leurs airbus avait
pris une avance technique sur les deux
géants boeing et douglas pourquoi airbus
le à 300 et bien parce qu'il est en ce
moment celui qui convient le mieux à
notre compagnie et aussi parce qu'il
nous permet d'économiser 25 % de
carburant par rapport aux autres avions
et je pense que l'achat de ses 23
premiers airbus n'est qu'une première
étape pour m'accompagner
où en est le finance et bien j'ai déjà
dit que ce qui est bon pour eastern est
bon pour nos banques
l'optimisme de boorman marquera la
réussite du projet arby's un avion vaut
150 millions de francs le marché conclu
avec l'amérique va faire d'abord le
bonheur des ateliers de toulouse
la france étant le maître d'oeuvre du
projet aux etats unis
d'autres compagnies a légué ni united
airlines notamment pourraient emboîter
le pas alors eva l'américain demain un
reportage de françois cornet sur le
premier vol du même appareil à moscou
cette fois chili on s'interroge
s'oriente-t-on vraiment vers une
libéralisation du régime toujours est il
qu'après le levée du couvre-feu général
pinochet a annoncé que tous les
prisonniers politiques
vairelles leur peine grasset ou commuée
en exil liban graves accrochages
hier après midi une patrouille
israélienne a été prise sous le feu de
ses vagues interet le tir trois ou
quatre israéliens ont trouvé la mort au
cours de cet incident et puis à
l'instant une dépêche c'est à d'autres
incidents entre des casques bleus
indiens et peut-être même français dit
la dépêche
avec des fedayins
c'est par le biais du sport que j'en
arrive à la marée noire la fédération
française de rugby en effet décidé de
faire payer une taxe de 2 francs à tous
les acheteurs de billets pour tous les
matchs qui vont se dérouler ce week-end
en chauffe et la france une centaine
entre une taxe qui est destiné à être
reversés aux sinistrés la marée noire
beaucoup d'autres initiatives mériterait
d'être signalé tél l'appel qu'a lancé de
la chambre de commerce franco-américaine
à la solidarité des états unis là encore
on attend des subsides conséquente qui
s'ajouteront aux allégations que
commence à recevoir dès maintenant
ceux qui habitent le finistère-nord et
les coded tout le monde sera indemnisé
mais personne ne tirera profit de cette
affaire marque beckham qui est le
coordonnateur envoyés sur place par le
gouvernement a tenu à faire cette
déclaration après la catastrophe
il est vrai que le pétrole plus assez
les plages comme ça il ne faut pas le
laisser polluer les esprits et pourtant
dans certaines communes des bruits
commencent à courir intel aurait touché
une grosse somme un autre aurait déclaré
un sinistré dans chacun se sent menacé
et la méfiance s'installe par endroits
car en effet parmi les quatre mille
sinistrés nul ne sait quel sera son
avenir ostréiculture près de 60
entreprises sont touchées en particulier
dans les abers la destruction des stocks
a été constaté sur place devant huissier
et remboursements seront faits en
fonction de la mortalité des huîtres les
ouvriers environ 500 personnes sont
considérées comme étant en chômage
économique reste à fixer le préjudice à
long terme
dans certains endroits le sol est imbibé
de mazout jusqu'à 50 cm de profondeur et
nous avons proposé le principe du
chômage économique était acceptée par
l'administration mais nous avons proposé
de les garder à notre service à
condition quand nous avancent les
salaires ça nous permettrait de
continuer à vaquer autres aux travaux
des parcs puisqu'un peu plus expédier et
d'autre part de mettre notre service nos
nos employés au service de la marée
noire les goémoniers 211 personnes
vivent de cette activité dans le secteur
sinistré
certains ont touché 12 144 francs par
quinzaine d'indemnisation plus les dons
distribués par quelques communes
mille francs en moyenne par famille la
plupart n'ont pas envoyé de dossiers
d'indemnisation la campagne des halles
doit en effet commencer le 15 avril dans
cinq ans ce qui est ce que les avons
repoussés sur les roches qui sont
atteintes
c'est un problème pour nous le problème
ne se pose pas actuellement dans les
jours à venir
donc ça c'est ce qu'on voit on voit on
voit les années qui vont venir c'est
surtout ça qui compte pour le gone in
parce que il ne sait pas c'est pour à 6
pour faire vivre sa famille s'il
pourrait payer ses traites de quoi ou
s'il faut qu'ils changent de métier ou
la pêche 1000 professionnels concernés
584 dossiers d'indemnisation à tous en
44 ans par quinzaine dans le finistère
le matériel est remboursé à 70%
les pêcheurs sont les plus touchés par
cette catastrophe avant l'accident
quinze jours de tempête les avait
empêchés de sortir de plus la période
actuelle d'avril à juin et celle du
poisson qui rapporte le lieu le mulet
l'araignée surtout alors 2500 francs par
mois pour eux c'est un peu ça
correspondrait pour la plupart je crois
à la plus mauvaise période de l'année
alors ça nous paraît plus ridicule
certains pêcheurs côtiers ne m'aurait
caché que pour eux c'était fini ils
n'ont pas les bateaux pour aller au
large et sur les autres comme on pollue
et ils ne connaissent pas les lieux de
pêche puis il ya les autres activités
économiques
celle là feront l'objet d'appréciations
au fur et à mesure de l'observation des
du préjudice
c'est ainsi par exemple que les
préjudices touristiques sont à évaluer
au moment de la saison touristique et
nous avons un espoir raisonnable mais un
espoir certain ils sont tous nos efforts
dans ce sens pour permettre à la saison
se dérouler normalement
reste le coût du plan polmar environ un
million de francs par jour pour le seul
nettoyage auxquelles s'ajoutent les
heures d'hélicoptère
on a beaucoup sur deûle est le problème
plus les journées de navigation jusqu'à
trente sept bateaux en mer pour traiter
les mares à propos de ces indemnisations
trois pêcheurs d'ouessant attendent
toujours les sommes qui leur sont dues
vingt mille francs chacun environ pour
destruction de matériel par
hydrocarbures
ils attendent depuis janvier 76 le
pétrolier responsable à l'époque c'était
l'olympique
aujourd'hui malheureusement le vent
souffle toujours du nordeste se vende
normés et pousser encore vers la côte et
pousse donc vers des nappes qui se
trouvait jusque alors au large
la marée noire a inspiré la parution de
deux nouveaux confrères don quichotte et
puis numéro spécial dont on nous dit que
c'est le premier magazine sur papier
recyclé là aussi inspirait la sortie
d'un très beau disque mais je vous le
dire pour la fin est parfait à l'origine
d'une manifestation qui a débuté une
heure à il ya une heure parlant à paris
place denfert rochereau manifestation à
l'appel des partis de gauche vous la cgt
la cfdt et des associations écologiques
une manifestation qui est en train de se
disperser mais il y à me dit on des
incidents y avait un coeur c'est
aujourd'hui à auteuil il fallait jouer
le 3 le 4 et le 2 les rapports vous les
voyez s'inscrire sur votre écran un peu
plus de 6000 francs dans l'ordre et un
peu plus de 800 francs dans un angle
différent tout cela pour 5 francs la
météo pour demain maintenant et bien le
ciel sera couvert sur les régions
méridionales il pleuvra dans les alpes
et le jura ailleurs et bien le temps
sera frais bien ensoleillé excepté sur
la manche sous les nuages resteront
abondantes
l'amélioration devrait se poursuivre ce
week-end samedi il y aura bien quelques
pluies sur les régions méridionales mais
ailleurs du vôtre et puis dimanche fera
c'est beau sur l'ensemble du pays même
si le ciel devient plus nuageux dans
l'après midi
une semaine après la province vous savez
si la région parisienne qui part en
vacances en vacances de printemps
après demain il vous est fortement
déconseillé de prendre la route samedi
de 8 heures à 12 heures partez avant ou
après nous immiscer un équipement
prochain journal patrick lecocq à 22h52
mais pour terminer comme promis voici
maintenant le disque dont je vous
parlais il est enregistré par les plus
grands chanteurs bretons au bénéfice des
sinistrés la marée noire propose
d'écouter la chanson de bienne mort qui
a donné son titre à l'ensemble du disque
il se meurt
nos voisins bonsoir à tout ça demain
savez-vous de temps
le père rabbin
le terme là
les marches au finisseur du cheikh
nasser a coulé le bateau chinois on
ok
oiseaux
savez-vous des temps où l'ordre avec
vous des crimes
on a bien été donnée une et le navire se
voulait la barre
il nous dira s'il annulera je sais pas
la guerre pour qu'ils ne reviennent pas
puisque chanter
savez-vous les temps où l' empire
d'argent on avait du courage et le
marchand des soldats
kim a tissé au fil des ans d'émettre
davantage
il est le rocher des meilleurs
lorsque chardy
aso
je sens qu il est temps
on a poteau témara où la vierge je garde
la voie de la bannière du conquérant
ils ont fui les temps où l'islam et non
de bataille et caban dessus le plus
poussé la canaille a violé la fille
d'une main car il chantait aux oiseaux
il semble même temps
ou l'enchère mis du sable le bâti c'est
l'océan et pour que juste sur la table
[ __ ] ce même à auchan il somme de
l'étang où l'argent du connétable achète
la mer à l'encan et pourquoi juste
reçoit la fable
la noire marée
et ce nombre du gréement qu'arrive
summer non
et